there are 200 million clinical cases of
falciparum malaria in Africa every year
resulting in half a million deaths I
would like to talk to you about malaria
vaccines the ones that we have made to
date are simply not good enough why
we've been working at it for a hundred
plus years when we started technology
was limited we could see just a tiny
fraction of what the parasite really
looked like today we are awash with
technology advanced imaging and omics
platforms genomics transcriptomics
proteomics these tools have given us a
clear view of just how complex the
parasite really is however in spite of
this our approach to vaccine design has
remained pretty rudimentary to make a
good vaccine we must go back to basics
to understand how our bodies handle this
complexity people who are frequently
infected with malaria learn to deal with
it they get the infection but they don't
get ill the recipe is encoded in
antibodies my team went back to our
complex parasite probed it with samples
from Africans who had overcome malaria
to answer the question what does a
successful antibody response look like
we found over 200 proteins many of which
are not on the radar for malaria
vaccines my research community may be
missing out important parts of the
parasite until recently when one had
identified
a protein of interest they tested
whether it might be important for a
vaccine by conducting a cohort study
this difficulty involved about 300
participants in a village in Africa
whose samples were analyzed to see
whether antibodies to the protein would
predict who got malaria and who did not
in the past 30 years these studies have
tested a small number of proteins in
relatively few samples and usually in
single locations the results have not
been consistent my team essentially
collapsed 30 years of this type of
research into one exciting experiment
conducted over just three months
innovatively we assembled 10,000 samples
from 15 locations in seven African
countries spanning time age and the
variable intensity of malaria
experienced in Africa we used omics
intelligence to prioritize our parasite
proteins synthesize them in the lab and
in short recreated the malaria parasite
on a chip we did this in Africa and
we're very proud of that
the chip is a small glass slide but it
gives us incredible power we
simultaneously gather data on over 100
antibody responses what are we looking
for the recipe behind a successful
antibody response so that we can predict
what might make a good malaria vaccine
we're also trying to figure out exactly
what antibodies do to the parasite how
do they kill it do they attack from
multiple angles is there synergy how
much activity do you need our studies
suggest that having a bit of one
antibody won't be enough it might take
high concentrations of antibodies
against multiple parasite proteins we're
also learning that antibodies kill the
parasite in multiple ways and studying
any one of these in isolation may not
adequately reflect reality just like we
can now see the parasite in greater
definition my team and I are focused on
understanding how our bodies overcome
this complexity we believe that this
could provide the breakthroughs that we
need to make malaria history through
vaccination thank you
okay how close are we actually to a
malaria vaccine we're just at the
beginning of a process to try and
understand what we need to put in the
vaccine before we actually start making
it so we're not really close to the
vaccine but we're getting there
and we're hopeful and we're very hopeful
tell me about smart tell me what does it
stand for and why is it important to you
so smart stands for South South malaria
antigen research partnership the South
South is referring to us in Africa
looking sideways to each other in
collaboration in contrast to always
looking to America and looking to Europe
when there is quite some strength within
Africa so in smart apart from the goal
that we have to develop a malaria
vaccine we're also training African
scientists because the burden of disease
in Africa is high and you need people
who will continue to push the boundaries
in science in Africa yes okay one last
question tell me how I know you
mentioned this a little bit but how
would things actually change if there
were a malaria vaccine we would save
half a million lives every year mm-hmm
200 million cases it's estimated that
malaria costs Africa 12 billion US
dollars a year so this is economics
Africa would simply thrive okay thank
you faith
thank you so much
[Applause]